I'd like to welcome you all to this
important event.
I would also like to apologize to those
among your friends,
relatives,
and colleagues who could not be here
today as the auditorium sold out in a
matter of hours.
My name is Joffrey Clarfield.
It is my privilege to be the executive
director of the speaker,
this action group,
and I would like to thank founding
president,
surely an haber and our new president
irving.
Why store and all the volunteers who've
worked so hard to make this event
happen.
I would also like to thank our partner
organization,
the Masood Freedom Foundation and the
council for Muslims facing tomorrow who
are the a joint sponsors of this event.
The speakers action group in particular
and it's supporting groups is dedicated
to the fight against antisemitism and
racism.
But without freedom of speech there
could be no fight against antisemitism
or racism for we need freedom of speech
to defend our rights
and as we will hear today,
freedom of speech is most threatened
where ironically it should be most tree
in the media and the colleges and the
universities of this country as well as
an other democracies.
I would like to introduce the emcee for
this afternoon.
Faith Goldie from the rebel media,
an organization that is at the forefront
of the fight for free speech in this
country.
I'd like her to introduce our two
distinguished speakers,
professor Jordan Peterson and Dr. Norman
doidge faith.
Thank you so much for being here today.
[inaudible]
been a dishwasher,
a gas shockey,
a bartender,
a short order cook,
a beekeeper apply wood mill laborer and
a railway line up worker.
But today professor Jordan B.
Peterson is best known for his work in
the academic world.
He has published more than 100
scientific papers transforming the
modern understanding of personality and
revolutionizing this psychology of
religion.
With his now classic book maps of
meaning the architecture of belief as a
Harvard professor,
he was nominated for the prestigious
Levinson teaching prize now at the
University of Toronto.
He is regarded by students as one of
their truly life changing teachers and I
think that I speak for a great deal of
people in this room and frankly across
the country when I say you need to be
one of Professor Peterson students to
have been enlightened and inspired by
that eight pound universe between his
ears as well as his bravery.
Yeah.
Most recently Dr. Peterson became the
center of an ongoing national
controversy for refusing to abide by the
University of attempt to put very
specific words into his mouth when they
ordered professors comply with the
gender pronouns policy,
Dr Peterson's vivid descent over
language politics and the political
agenda behind it has seen him threatened
and showed it down by snowflake students
and the academic hierarchy alike as a
result of his public views on how
political correct nate's correctness
rather violates freedom of speech and
academic freedom.
And the west Professor Peterson has
become a cultural icon for liberty
lovers and a long awaited obstruction to
the wayfairs on the long march of the
institution's.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Jordan
bpt
[inaudible].
So about
three months ago
I sat in my office at night.
I wasn't really sleeping very well and
because my mind was running and it was
running because I had just read some
policy documents on the Ontario Human
Rights Commission website in
relationship to build see 16 and at the
same time I had heard that the
University of Toronto hr and equity
vice president had decided to make anti
unconscious bias training mandatory for
her staff,
which I find appalling
and still find a polling.
And I would recommend that if any of you
are asked or required to have your
unconscious biases adjusted,
that you might see some,
you might note to yourself that by
agreeing to do so,
you have agreed that you're guilty and I
wouldn't recommend that.
Anyways,
I was mostly trying to straighten up my
thoughts on these issues,
you know?
And,
and that's usually what I do when I
speak,
you know,
because,
and I have a good reputation as a
speaker and I think there's two reasons
for that.
And one is I don't ever speak to a
group.
I always speak to individuals,
you know,
I'm not speaking to the group,
I'm speaking to individual people and
I'm not telling you what's right because
I don't know what's right.
What I'm trying to do is to formulate my
thoughts more clearly.
And it's helpful to do that in speech,
even in front of an audience because
it's a dialogue with an audience.
You know,
if you watched the individuals,
then they,
you can tell if they're following you or
whether mostly whether they're following
you,
if they can understand the line of the
argumentation.
And some of them will be shaking their
heads and some of them will be nodding.
And you know,
some of it will be looking puzzled in
which case you have to kind of
reformulate.
And so,
and that's,
that's how I,
that's how to think,
you know,
and,
and when you're speaking to people,
it's okay to tell them what you know,
but better to show them how you think.
And that means you're going to stumble
around like an idiot some of the time
because you're trying to grapple with
things.
And what I tried to do for my students
is to,
to model the process of grappling with
things.
Because that's what you do when you
think,
and you know,
Norman pointed out that you can be right
or you can try to get smarter and to be
right.
Then you convince people that you're
right,
but to try to get smarter,
you find out why you're wrong.
And so I decided a long time ago,
one of the ways to deal with Maya
authoritarian tendencies,
let's say,
was to make friends with what I don't
know instead of what I do know.
And that's a whole different way of
looking at the world,
you know,
and it's,
it's got its pain because you know,
you're always trying to figure out more
or less wire an abayas moron.
And that's a very long list of,
that's a very,
you have a very long list of reasons for
that.
And then you have to find out why you're
wrong.
And as a short term mechanism for
attaining psychological stability,
I wouldn't recommend it.
But as a long term process where you're
trying to make things work better in the
medium to longterm,
then it's the only way.
But,
but you know,
it's easy to sacrifice the future for
the present,
although it's kind of the reverse of the
way you should do things.
So anyways,
I made these videos,
pretty amateur videos and you know,
the lighting wasn't very good and
there's a bunch of things wrong with
them and a buck.
One of the things I've been wondering
about for the last three months,
it's just what,
what happened?
Like,
what's going on here?
This is crazy.
And,
you know,
I've been accused of a lot of things,
some of which are no doubt true.
But you know,
I've been accused of being a racist and
being a trans fold.
But what else?
Profiteering and uh,
I guess the other one was
scaremongering.
Yeah,
that's the other one.
Scaremongering and so of course I'd been
wondering if that,
if those things are true because it's
not like,
you know,
my heart is as pure as the driven snow
hardly and everyone has biases and all
of that.
So,
and I also,
well this unfolded had a group of
friends who were definitely critics who
were watching everything I was doing and
you know,
letting me know pretty forthrightly when
I was being arrogant and when I was,
you know,
look kind of disheveled and when my
arguments were just clear as they could
be and you know,
and so on.
These were smart people and their
comments were very incisive.
And then of course I had all the blow
back and I was paying attention to it,
you know,
because well,
you should pay attention to such things.
And so,
and I do pay attention to things.
You know,
that's the thing.
I actually pay attention to things and
if I'm embroiled in a controversy,
even if it's a like problem in my home,
I tried to get to the damn bottom of it.
And you know,
the bottom of things is not a pretty
place to look.
And so you know,
when you're arguing with someone at
home,
even someone you love,
you'll notice that your argument can get
out of hand a pretty quick.
So if you're arguing with your wife or
your husband,
you know,
it depends on how volatile you are of
course.
But you know,
you start
arguing about some little thing and then
you come to understand pretty quick that
it's actually not about that little
thing at all.
That little thing is associated with,
you know,
a little bigger thing underneath that.
And maybe that's associated with even a
bigger thing under that.
And you know,
soon you're taking each other apart for
assuming you've been married for 20
years,
for all the stupid things you've done to
each other over the last 20 years.
And it doesn't have to end there.
And how it's not pleasant,
it's really hard to bind a conversation
so it doesn't go everywhere,
you know?
So one thing you can do if you're
talking to someone about something you
disagree with someone you love,
you can tell them a bunch of good things
about what they've been doing,
which you actually believe.
And then just say,
well,
but there's this little problem here.
And I just like it adjusted in a minor
way.
And maybe that'll,
you know,
we'll sort things out a bit between us
and then maybe you don't fall into that
stupid pit,
which is really easy to fall into.
And you know,
which certainly can lead to divorce
among other things.
And so a huge part of the issue always
is just exactly what is this about?
Well,
I'd been asking myself that question for
a long,
long time because I'd been interested in
authoritarian conflict and atrocity and
totalitarianism for way longer than
anyone with any sanity should ever be
interested in it.
And you know,
and then this,
and then this all came up and I thought,
okay,
okay.
It's like,
all right,
well,
you know,
am I a bigot and a transformed?
Well,
I probably have my biases because people
tend to have in group biases,
you know,
and that's associated by the way with
compassion.
Just so you know it because one of the
things compassion does is make you much,
strongly,
much more strongly bound to your
ingroup.
You know,
it's like a mother as compassionate
cause she loves her baby and she loves
the baby more than other things that
aren't the baby obviously.
And so actually compassion is one of the
main sources of Ingroup bias,
which is something for the compassion
warriors to think about for like three
fifths of a second.
There's,
there's nothing less compassionate to
you than a mother.
Grizzly bear protecting her cubs.
And so you should think about that when
you think about empathy for a minute,
because empathy is by no means an
untrammeled moral virtue.
In fact,
it's responsible and can be responsible
for absolutely atrocious actions.
It depends on who you're empathizing
with,
you know,
and if you are empathizing with someone
that you regard as an infant dialyzed
victim,
then you snap into a frame of mind where
everyone who might be oppressing that
infant dialyzed victim is a predatory
parasite and you're not very bloody
empathetic to them.
I can tell you.
So now it's a big problem anyways with
regards to this scaremongering issue.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Biased.
Yeah,
probably and blind definitely.
Um,
like more than,
more than you might expect.
No,
I don't think so.
And one of the things that actually
protected me through all of this was
that,
you know,
I've actually tried to come to terms
with the evil that lurks in human
hearts,
particularly my own.
And I have 500 hours of lectures on that
online.
If anybody has the bizarre desire to
pound their way through them,
they can more or less think,
figure out what I think because I said
500 of hours of it publicly and so I
didn't feel too bad about my level of
bigotry or hatred,
you know,
I think you could probably infer that by
watching the video.
So it's kind of protected on that front.
And then there was this scaremongering
issue and that's a good one.
That's a tough one man.
Because you know,
if you look at bill [inaudible] 16 it
just kind of looks like,
well we're extending protection to
another oppressed group,
which isn't actually true because gender
identity,
by the way,
no gender expression,
that's not a group I'd like just like to
point that out because terminological
accuracy actually matters.
So we've extended legal protection to
fashion essentially.
And you can say,
well maybe I'm being a bit intransigent
about that,
but I read the Dat and policies and I
don't think I am.
And that's not a group.
So that's an indication of the muddle
headedness behind the legislation.
And then the federal government,
the Department of Justice did say on
their own website that they were going
to interpret that law in light of the
policies of the Ontario Human Rights
Commission.
And so fine man,
go to the Ontario Human Rights
Commission if they haven't taken the
policies off yet and read what they're
up to.
And if that,
if you agree with that,
well good green with it.
But I would suspect that if you agree
with it,
you didn't,
you didn't understand it or,
or,
or you're up to something and now it
comes to the next part.
What are,
what are we really talking about here?
Well,
so we could be talking about my biases
is my proclivity to scaremonger and you
know,
fair enough,
but here's some reasons we're not.
And one is that I have all those
lectures online and you know,
believe me,
if there would've been a phrase in any
of them that indicated that there was
something even vaguely morally corrupt
about me,
it would have been paraded around as
evidence.
You can be sure of that.
So that's kind of a relief.
You know,
I did a lot of soul searching in the
last couple of months and it's not like
I'm without my problems.
But anyways.
So what is this about?
Well we'll say,
hopefully it's not about me because
that'd be stupid.
And so what,
what's going on?
Why are all these people watching these
videos,
these things I made just to figure out
what it was that I was thinking.
You know,
cause I couldn't sleep one night and
because I'm not very damn happy about
that unconscious bias stuff,
which I regard as absolutely
reprehensible,
that you could be held guilty for your
implicit perceptions.
Think about that.
God,
they use that test as a diagnostic test.
You know,
it doesn't meet the criteria for
reliability and validity that you'd use
for a diagnostic test.
It doesn't produce the same results one
time after another.
And you can use it to target anybody.
And so go along with it if you want and
just see what happens.
Anyways.
Yeah,
so I've been thinking about this like
what's going on?
Why the outcry,
you know,
you think,
well Professor Peterson,
God is 15 minutes of fame.
It's like,
well I had my 15 minutes of,
you know,
trivial fame several times in my life
and there's some good things about it,
but I am despite what you might think or
rather private person.
And so it's not like I'm particularly
enjoying it,
but I thought something,
you know,
when I made those videos I thought this
is something I learned from reading
mythology.
If you have to fight a dragon,
you should go to it slayer before it
comes to your village.
And so people think of what I did is
courageous and I don't think that's
right.
I just think that I can see danger
coming and you get to pick,
you get to pick your anxiety.
I could either be anxious about speaking
or I could be anxious about not
speaking.
And so I chose to be anxious about
And that's not exactly courage.
It's more like common sense without
assumes that you're looking into the
future.
So are you might say,
well,
what gives me any special power to look
into the future and hey,
that's a good question and my God only
knows what's going to happen in the next
few years.
You know,
I did read today,
this is cool.
250,000 people will be lifted out of
absolute poverty today and 300,000 more
will be connected to electricity and
we're knocking poverty rates around the
world down faster by a huge margin than
we ever have in human history.
There was an article in New York Times
today called y 2016 was the best year
ever.
It's really worth reading.
I concluded the same thing.
I worked for a UN committee a couple of
years ago when I was looking at,
you know,
what was going to happen down the road
and everything.
I kept reading less while,
wow,
we're getting rid of polio.
We're getting rid of LFA elephantiasis,
which you really don't want to have.
We're getting rid of Guinea worm.
We're getting rid of polio,
knock and malaria back into the swamps
from where it comes.
We're lifting people out of poverty.
It's like,
man,
we're doing a lot of good things.
You'd sure never guessed that by the way
we treat ourselves.
So anyways,
so what's going on?
Okay,
so I thought,
well I better think about this.
I've been thinking about a long time.
So
you know,
the,
the right wing is really hard on the
Frankfurt school,
you know,
and the Frankfurt school where these
kinds of neo Marxist guys who combined
Marxism with
Friday and Islam in the 1940s and,
and they were avowed neo Marxists,
you know,
so it's not like I'm making an
accusation and they were kind of anti
system type people and,
and all of that.
But I think to lay what's happening at
the universities and in brought in the
broader culture itself at the feet of
the Frankfurt school is insufficient.
I really think that it's primarily a
consequence of the French intellectuals
who,
and this is obviously an
oversimplification who emerged out of
Marxism in the early 1970s and produce
postmodernism.
Now,
the thing about the postmodernist types
is there nested inside mark's is they
say that straight out,
I'm not inventing this.
You read Derrida,
who's like the,
the joker at the,
at the head of the postmodernist
movement.
And I,
I mean joker because he's,
he's,
he's an intellectual clown and not,
doesn't mean he's stupid because he is
not stupid.
Not at all.
These people are not stupid.
They know exactly what they're doing.
They know precisely what they're doing.
They're a hell of a lot more educated
about what they're doing.
Then you are less,
you happen to be one of them.
And they mean exactly what they say.
Just like people always do when they
tell you what they're going to do or
they write it down and they say straight
out on their websites say that women's
studies websites,
we think the patriarchy is an oppressive
structure that should be broken down to
its core.
And they meet core conceptions.
It's not just social,
it's linguistic,
philosophical and attitudinal.
It should be broken down.
What wiped out and restructured from the
bottom up.
And they mean that.
So when it's not accidental.
Any of this,
and I know it sounds like a bloody
paranoid conspiracy theory,
but you know I've,
I've always been of the idea,
especially from reading young,
that ideas people don't have ideas,
ideas have people and these are powerful
ideas.
There's a good book called explaining
postmodernism that I might recommend by
a guy named named Steven RC Hicks and
his first chapter,
which isn't very long.
It's a good introduction to political
correctness,
but so while,
so why do I think this is about,
about that?
Well her,
here's my reasons.
I mean it doesn't seem to be about me.
I think all idea to actually was
actually,
I made the general specific k,
which is kind of what you have to do if
you really want to make a point,
a point,
right?
That's one place.
If you want to make a point.
And my point was,
I'm not saying made up words generated
by postmodern neo Marxists because I
despise everything they stand for.
And so I'm not using those damn words
and that's okay.
No,
I'd like,
I have something against transgender
people.
I'm sure some of them are lovely people
and some of them aren't,
you know,
and so they can do whatever they want as
far as I'm concerned,
as long as they don't,
they can do whatever they want as far as
I'm concerned,
as long as I'm not forced to go along
with the most radical representatives of
them who don't even speak for them
anyways.
I've got like 20 letters from
transsexual people supporting what I've
done and like none opposing it.
You know,
one of the things that's kind of cool is
I've only got three hate letters.
I thought three,
Jesus,
you guys,
you guys are,
you guys aren't trying very hard.
And I got like a thousand letters of
support and if you go on youtube where
I'm radically overrepresented,
um,
and you look at the comments and the
likes and the dislikes,
it's about the same ratio.
It's like likes to dislikes is like
about a hundred to one and almost all
the comments are positive,
which you know,
could easily be a selection bias and
probably is,
but you know,
it still means that there's quite a few
people who think that what I'm doing is
sort of okay as far as they're
concerned.
And so that's important.
So anyways,
we need to talk a little bit about
postmodernism.
Okay.
So let's go back to France in the 19 end
of the 1960.
So,
and this is of course an
oversimplification and I'm sure I'm
wrong about some of it because you know,
it's not exactly my field of speciality,
this sort of sociology.
Um,
I'm more of the scientist tight,
but,
and I,
and if I read philosophy,
I tend not to read second rate
philosophy.
And so I've tried to avoid the
postmodernists to some degree because
there are,
there any coherency is one of the least
of their sins.
But they don't care about that.
No,
no.
You've got to understand,
man,
it's modernists 10 enlightenment people
and even traditionalist who care about
coherency,
the postmodernists don't believe in
coherency.
They don't believe in,
and I'm not making this up,
this is part of their philosophy.
They don't believe in logic.
You know,
debt does says straight out that Western
society has fellow logo centric by which
he means male centered and privileging
the idea of logic.
Well,
he doesn't buy any of that.
He doesn't think that there's a truth
that is out there.
He doesn't believe that individuals can
reach any sort of truth by thinking.
He certainly doesn't believe that we can
move towards truth in dialogue because
that's dialogic,
right?
There's none of that.
You wonder,
well why don't,
why did the postmodern types keep other
thinkers off the campus?
Well,
it's not because they're afraid.
Well also some of the market,
but they use their fragility as a mask
for their,
you know,
the underlying philosophical,
their underlying philosophical and
political interests.
They do that Freidman terribly.
It's not like every social justice
warrior is,
uh,
you know,
soared carrie and pork postmodernists
but the idea are fragmented and
distributed among them.
Like they're distributed among a mob.
And if you put the whole mob together,
you get the whole post modernists thing
happening at the same time.
And that's how ideas have people instead
of the other way around.
Anyways,
forget about logic.
That's out the window.
That's just a construct of Western
society and,
and the whole point of the construct was
to oppress other people and to take
their wealth and to privilege the people
who live within that so called logic
system so that they can justify to
themselves and other people their prey
Predator rapaciousness straight and
simple.
And that's partly because postmodernism
was influenced by Marxism.
And of course that's what the Marxists,
think about any situation where there's
a,
let's call it a power status
differential.
The people at the top are only there
because they've stole everything from
the people at the bottom.
And so the knee,
the Marxists in France realized by the
end of 1960s there abouts when even John
Paul Sartre finally figured out that to
be a communist probably wasn't
acceptable given that the bloody Soviet
had killed like 30 million people
between 1919 and 1959 and the Maoists
done the same thing on a greater scale
in China.
And then we talk about North Korea and
we can talk about,
you know,
by whatever,
we don't,
students don't learn any of that in
school anymore.
And even if they did,
they wouldn't want to listen to it.
When I tell my students in my second
year psychology class about the Gulag
archipelago,
hardly any of them know,
well why is that?
Well,
it's because they haven't been taught
it.
Why is that?
Well,
see if you can figure it out.
All right,
so,
so anyways,
back to the postmodern types.
So you know,
it got to the point where there's just
no way you could be a Marxist,
especially after social knits.
And because Solzhenitsyn wrote this
great book,
which is actually out of print for
crying out loud,
which I've actually been able to
popularize like mad over the last three
months,
which is,
you know,
really mind boggling and what soldier
Nitsa did in his genius manner because
he's up there with Dostoevsky and
tolstoy like,
man,
that guy,
he's a towering intellect and a person
of tack can or moral force,
you know,
like he put himself on the line for that
book.
He memorized it when he was in the,
in the prison camps.
It's about,
it's three volumes that fic,
you know,
it's like 2000 pages of someone's
screaming.
The smartest person you've ever met,
the wisest person you've ever met,
screaming and outrage for 2000 pages.
It's no bloody wonder.
It's out of print.
Anyways,
what soldier in its did was
take on this claim.
You often hear the radical leftists make
about communism,
about Marxism.
They say,
well,
that wasn't real Marxism.
It's like,
okay,
well how many countries do you need to
disprove your thesis?
How many millions of people have to die
before you might admit that you're
wrong.
Well,
obviously more than a hundred million
because that's the approximate total of,
that's probably an underestimate,
but we'll be conservative because I had
to get another 10 million.
Doesn't really make that much
difference.
So soldier Nansen took that argument
apart partly in his book lending in
Zurich,
and then partly in the Gulag
archipelago.
Buck groundwork had already been laid
for all of that by nature,
who knew exactly what was coming in the
20th century and by Dostoyevsky who
wrote a book called the possess back in
like 1880 where he outlined in painful
detail the precise mindset that would
produce the Russian revolution like 30
years later.
Amazing and Tolstoy as well.
He's,
he knew what was coming and made him
suicidal.
He wrote in his confession that win
the conflict between the ideas of
Russia,
the traditional ideas and the
enlightenment ideas sweeping in from the
west,
they,
they blew his worldview apart,
which was traditional religious blew his
worldview apart so badly that he was
suicidal at the height of his fame.
Tolstoy knew what was going to come to.
And so it's not like soldier Mitson was
the only person who could see this or
are we all knew it.
Uh,
Malcolm Muggeridge knew it in the 1930s
what he was noting that the Soviets,
given their idea of class guilt,
which sounds a lot like white privilege
to me or any other form of racism,
they use that doctrine to just round up
all the Kulaks they were the productive
farmers and ship them off to Siberia and
then 6 million Ukrainian starve to
death.
But you know,
they had too many Ukrainians anyway,
so it didn't really matter.
So anyways,
back to the postmodern types.
Well,
you know,
this all came was revealed in such
painful detail that even the kind of
closed minded India log that Norman
referred to just quite,
couldn't,
couldn't quite muster up the moral
courage to keep beating the same damn
drum.
So what they did instead being highly
intelligent individuals was play a game
of sleight of hand and transformed these
marks,
his presuppositions into postmodernism
in the 1970s.
And the idea basically was,
well,
the working class isn't going to rise up
and crush the burrs,
waze,
because first of all they're getting
rich and that wasn't supposed to happen.
And second,
well,
it's sorted seemed to be a catastrophe
when that occurred,
let's say in Russia.
And so maybe we won't do that anymore
because the working class actually isn't
buying into this either,
which is also a problem,
you know,
having internalized their own
oppression,
they wouldn't buy into this,
to the global myth of Utopia.
So maybe it's because they had some
sense.
It's certainly possible.
But anyways,
the slight of hand was,
oh,
well fine,
we'll just play a different,
oh,
oppressor versus gain and we'll
introduce identity politics.
It's like,
okay,
okay.
You're not being oppressed because
you're a member of the working class.
You're being oppressed because you're a
woman or you're being oppressed because
you have an ethnicity that's outside the
main paradigm,
whatever that might be.
Um,
or it's because of your,
your,
your sexual preference or your sexual
identity or whatever.
Whatever places you in some manner
outside the normative culture.
And you know,
the thing is the postmodernist you
don't,
you might think,
well your culture is good for something.
It gives you a hierarchy of value.
It rewards competent people.
It gives you a direction so you can
climb up,
you know,
cause otherwise everything's leveled to
nothing.
And then why do anything?
Well,
they don't care about any of that.
They don't believe that there's any such
thing as competence.
thing as up.
This is all postmodernism wipes,
all of that out.
And so when the postmodernist tantalize
the text,
all they care about is how it privileges
the position of the author and who had
impresses.
And that's the only thing they regard as
real.
And they don't believe in grand unifying
narratives.
They don't believe that there's a
Canadian identity.
They don't believe that there's an
American identity.
They don't believe that there's a
western identity.
They don't believe that value structures
exist.
Or if they are,
there are replaceable.
With some other value structure,
they certainly don't believe that they
have any biological grounding that
there's any such thing as a human being.
It's all socially constructed,
which is really convenient if what you
want to do is be the author of an
entirely social constructed you utopia
that you can run.
And then when the marks is say,
well that wasn't real Marxism,
what it really means,
and I've thought about this for a long
time,
it's the most arrogant possible
statement anyone could ever make.
It means if I would've been installing
his position,
I would have,
I sure didn't the damn utopia instead
that instead of the genocidal massacres,
because I understand the doctrine of
Marxism and everything about me is good.
It's like well think again sunshine,
you don't understand it,
you don't understand it and you're not
that good.
And if the power was in your hands,
assuming you had the competence,
which you don't,
you wouldn't have done any better.
And even if you had,
there would have been someone else
waiting right behind you to shoot you
the first time you actually tried to do
anything good.
And that's what happened to all of the
old guard who ran the damn revolution.
Stalin rounded them all up and shot them
along with their families and millions
of other people.
So even if you do happen to be that
Avatar of moral purity that you claim
implicitly,
the probability that you'd give it to
act out your goodness in relationship to
those possessed by Your radiology is
zero.
So it's
so,
you know,
you think,
well,
why are these postmodern is doing what
they're doing?
Why did they oppose the patriarchic?
Here's a question,
why don't the feminists complaining
about Saudi Arabia?
It's like,
you know,
God sod,
who's this guy up concordia who is in a
business school so he can actually say
what he thinks now.
And then he tweeted yesterday,
well,
hey,
see tweeted to the woman's march.
You know,
cause there's little twitter thing you
could do that I suppose for the
organizers.
And he said,
why don't you go to the Middle East and
have a nice march again Saudi Arabia and
see,
see how that works out for Ya.
It's like,
so you think,
well,
why not?
Like why not?
Why?
Why are the why or the radical left as
to are so much for rights everywhere.
That's what they say.
Why aren't they complaining about Saudi
Arabia,
for example,
which you know,
breeds a particularly pathological form
of video,
logically rigid Islam that basically in
slaves they're women.
That's to put it properly.
It's like why not complain about that?
Well how about this?
The enemy of my enemy is my friend.
Yeah.
And so when push comes to shove,
you see how much concern there is among
the radical feminists for the rights of
women.
It's like if the,
if the pushing those rights forward
doesn't also at the same time under a
undermine the western patriarchy,
then we'll take the undermining and
leave the damn rights behind.
And so there's an insight for you about
exactly what's going on at the bottom of
all of this.
So,
okay,
so then there's another weird thing,
and I've already sort of hit on it
tangentially.
It's like,
well the postmodernists don't believe in
grand unifying narratives.
They don't believe in narratives at all.
They don't care about value because they
never know.
You have to value something in,
in order to have some hope in life,
right?
Because when you value something,
you're pursuing it.
And in the pursuit,
that's where the meaning in life is,
you know,
cause the rest of it's suffering.
If you're trying to struggle upwards
towards the light,
it's like,
well that's something to motivate you
and to protect you against the
suffering.
But the postmodernists don't care about
any of that.
And I would say it's because they don't
care about suffering.
Okay.
So all right,
so here,
but here's the,
here's the final question.
It's like,
well,
if the postmodernists don't care about
grand unifying narratives and they don't
believe in identity,
why in the world are they willing to
believe in gender identity and sexual
identity and racial identity and ethnic
identity?
And the answer to that is,
well,
they can't,
but they don't care because coherence
isn't on their agenda.
And besides that,
when push comes to shove,
they're postmodernism is nested inside a
deeper Marxism.
And so when the postmodern narrative
doesn't suffice,
say to push forward,
the idea that Western civilization
should be overturned,
they just revert back to the over
arching Marxism and say,
well,
those people are oppressed and that's a
bad thing.
It's like you might say,
well,
you're a postmodernist.
It's like you'll believe in any of that.
And they say,
well,
yeah,
I'm only a postmodernist this deep.
But underneath that there's a,
and I can always rely on that to fill in
the gaps and that's exactly what's
happening.
So,
so that's what's happening as far as I
can tell.
And you know,
so why do I believe this will all,
there's a little war going on in our
culture.
Maybe it's not so little.
I put my finger on it and I wouldn't
recommend that,
by the way.
You know,
because okay,
you explain it man.
You explain why.
Like 3 million people have watched the
UFT free speech rally and I think 7
million people downloaded the Joe Rogan
podcast.
And it's like crazy.
It's crazy.
There was 180 newspaper articles about
this.
It was news for four months.
Why?
Who cares what I think,
God,
I don't even care that much about what
I,
what about trump?
What's going on there?
Exactly.
You know,
it was interesting listening to trump's
inauguration speech because I detected
elements of national socialists thought
in it,
you know,
and not being dismissive.
I'm seriously not being dismissive,
but when you radically activate on the
side of the left,
you call forth compensate Tory forces
and they're not in your control.
And like trump opened his speech,
he just read it.
It's,
he sounds like a 1950 socialist,
you know,
he's going to use the power of the state
to bring the industry home to produce a
lot of infrastructure.
It's a state business unity with the
state in charge.
And then at the end of his speech,
which is where he stopped speeding,
at least the international kind of
socialist,
he says,
well borders are really important and so
is national identity.
And you know,
he does embed that within belief in God,
which is probably a good thing,
assuming that he's serious about that.
But you know,
the fact that trump was elected in the
end,
that there was such a fight between him
and the Clintonites and,
and that the Clinton nights were playing
identity politics instead of speaking
for the working class,
who then trump co-opted like he should
have.
Um,
there there's a war going on there.
And then what,
what about brexit?
What's going on there?
And what about France with Marine Le Pen
and what about Holand with wielders,
you know,
watch it.
We're in a chaotic time and you know,
I've gotten letters from people all over
the world who tell me how they can't say
what they think.
It's like,
oh,
well that's not very good.
And they're kind of happy with me
because maybe they think that I
emboldened them in some way and so good.
Good for that.
Hypothetically.
And most of the people who wrote me the
overwhelming majority were reasonable.
So pretty happy about that too.
But,
and maybe I'm wrong about my damn
diagnosis because like what do I know?
But I do have this proclivity to get to
the bottom of things and what's out the
bottom of this as an ideological war or
philosophical war.
It's even deeper than that.
It might even be deeper than a
philosophical board,
which is something that's more like a
metaphysical or theological war.
You know?
It depends on how far down you look and
the know exactly what they're doing.
This isn't accidental.
Of course,
you shut down speakers you don't agree
with because you can't have a dialogue
with him then anyways,
because human beings can't have
dialogue.
There's no such thing as a human
individual.
There's no such thing as truth.
Here's the postmodern world.
It's the hubs Z and nightmare.
It's everyone against everyone else
except it's not individuals.
It's groups and you're stuck in your
damn group and it's the only thing about
you.
Anyways,
that's relevant,
which is why we might base our hiring on
it,
for example,
and you're oppressed and even if you
don't know it just only because you've
internalized it and it's the only thing
that's real about you.
Anyways and I can't talk to you because
I'm in my own little silo of privileged
belief.
And besides we can't use logic because
that doesn't exist.
And so you're in a group and I'm in a
group and all we can do is have a war or
we can talk,
but we don't get to talk cause he can't
talk if you're a postmodernist because
speech is just chatter.
So when it's just chatter that supports
the people in power,
that's how they think.
And so the whole world is this little
armed war of identity group against
identity group against identity group.
And you shut down people who don't agree
with you because why should you let them
talk?
It's you don't believe in any of the
reasons why you would let someone talk.
So this isn't accidental.
It's not because they're afraid.
Although it's also because of that they
hijack,
you know,
fear,
they hijack compassion.
They make anyone who who puts forward an
alternative view into a terrorist of
ideas and someone who's heartless at the
core,
which is really incredibly intelligent.
It's such a good strategy.
It's so devious and brilliant and it's
so effective because who wants to,
who the hell wants to be labeled a
bigot?
You probably are a damn big.
It just like everyone else.
So you know when it's easy to make
people feel guilty about that,
maybe they should.
So anyways,
what's going on?
Well that's what's going on.
And so what do you do about it?
Well,
I don't know what you do about it,
but I haven't theory.
And that's when I'd been working on for
like 40 years.
So one of the problems with
postmodernism,
and I'm going to take five minutes and
then we're done.
One of the problems with postmodernism
is that,
and this is a big problem,
like this is a fatal problem,
apart from the fact that it's incoherent
and there's no value structure in it and
it's fundamentally divisive and
destructive.
There's a logical problem with a two
that's even worse.
And so you might be noticing that the
lgbt set of acronyms keeps growing hay
and it,
it's,
it's Kinda,
it's kind of a form of it's own parody
in some sense.
It's like,
well,
I'm oppressed.
It's like,
yeah,
you are.
And while I'm impressed too,
yeah,
you're also oppressed and maybe I'm even
pressing you being part of this other
marginalized group,
but at least we share oppression.
Well,
I'm also oppressed.
so am I.
I'm oppressed too.
It's like,
okay,
so here's the problem.
There's a big problem here.
The problem is,
it's true.
You're oppressed,
you're oppressed,
you're oppressed.
God only knows why.
Maybe you're too short,
or you know what,
as beautiful as you could be,
or you know,
your parent,
your grandparent was a surf likely
because almost everybody's granted great
grandparent was,
it's like,
you know,
and you're not as smart as he could be.
And you have a sick relative and you
have your own physical problems.
And it's like,
frankly,
you're a mass and you're oppressed in
every possible way,
including your ancestry and your
biology.
And the entire sum of human history has
conspired to produce,
victimized you with all your individual
pathological problems.
It's like,
yes,
true.
Okay.
But the problem is,
is that it is true.
And so if you take the oppressed,
you have to fractionate them and
fractured ate them.
It's like you're a woman.
Yeah.
Okay,
well,
I'm a black woman.
Well,
I'm a black woman who has two children.
I'm a black woman who has two children
and one of them isn't very healthy and
then,
well,
I'm a,
I'm a Hispanic woman and I have a genius
son who doesn't have any money so that
he cannot go to university and you know,
I had a hell of a time getting across
the border.
It was really hard on me to get my
citizenship and my husband is an
alcoholic brute.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
that sucks too and so well,
so let's,
let's,
let's fix all your oppressive oppression
and we'll take every single thing into
account and then we'll fix yours too.
We'll take every single thing into
account.
It's like,
no,
you won't because you can't.
You can't.
It is technically impossible.
First of all,
you can't even list all the ways that
you're oppressed.
Second,
how are you going to weight them?
Third,
who's going to decide,
and that's the bloody thing.
Who's going to decide?
That's the thing.
Well,
what's the answer in the West?
It's like in free markets.
Oh yeah.
Christ will never be able to solve this
problem.
No one can solve it.
What are we going to do about that?
We're going to outsource it to the
marketplace.
You're going to take your,
sorry,
pathetic being and you're going to try
to offer me something that may be I want
and I'm going to take my story pathetic
being,
and I'm going to say,
well,
all things considered as well as I can
understand that maybe I could give you
this much money,
which is actually a promise for that
thing and you've packed all of your damn
old pressured into the price and I've
packed on my oppression into the
willingness to pay it and that solution
sucks.
It's a bad solution.
But compared to every other solution,
man,
it's white.
10% of us have freedom.
And so there,
there's a tremendous illogic at the
bottom of this.
It's like
you have to fraction eight theo pressed
all the way down to the level of the
individual.
Well,
that's what the West figured out.
You know,
there's a couple of figures who at the
mythological roots of our culture,
and you know,
people get upset with me because I bring
in religious themes,
but I understand some things about
mythology and religion.
It's not an accident that the axiomatic
western individual is someone who was
unfairly nailed to a cross and torture.
It's like,
yes.
Right.
Exactly.
So what do you do about that?
Well,
I thought about that for a long time
too.
It's like,
well,
you don't get together in a damn Bob,
because all that does is allow you to be
as horrible as you could possibly
imagine and suffer from none of the
consequences.
That's a bad idea.
So how about we don't do that?
Well,
there's a deep idea in the west too.
It's like,
pick up your damn suffering and Barrett.
Okay.
And try to be a good person so you don't
make it worse.
Okay,
well that's a truth.
You know,
I read a lot about the terrible things
that people have done to each other.
You just cannot even imagine it so
awful.
So you don't want to be someone like
that?
No.
Do you have a reason to be?
Yes.
You have a lots of reasons to be God.
There's reasons to be resentful about
your existence.
Everyone you know is going to die.
You know you too,
and there's going to be a fair bit of
pain along the way and lots of it's
going to be unfair.
It's like,
yeah,
no wonder you're resentful.
It's like act it out and see what
happens.
You make everything you're complaining
about infinitely worse.
There's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad is some stupid son of a
bitch,
like you could figure out a way to make
it a lot worse.
So you think,
well,
what do you do about that?
Well,
you accept it.
That's what life is like.
It's suffering.
That's what the religious people have
always said,
life is suffering.
Yes.
Well,
who wants to admit that?
just think about it.
Well,
so what do you do in the face of that
suffering?
Try to reduce it.
Yeah,
start with yourself.
What good are you?
Get yourself together for Christ sake so
that when your father dies,
you're not wining away in a corner and
you can help plan the funeral and you
can stand up solidly so that people can
rely on you.
That's better.
Who'll be a damn victim course.
You're a victim.
Jesus obviously
put yourself together and then maybe if
you put yourself together,
you know how to do that.
You know what's wrong with you,
if you'll admit it,
you know there's a few things you could
like paulie sharp a little bit that you
might even be able to manage.
You're insufficient present condition
and so you might shine yourself up a
little bit and then your eyes will be a
little more open.
Then you can sign yourself up a little
bit more and then maybe you could bring
your family together instead of having
them be the hateful,
spiteful,
neurotic in fighting batch that you're
like doom to spend Christmas with.
So then you fix yourself up a little
bit,
kind of humbly because you know God,
you're a fixer upper.
If there ever was one and then you got
to figure out,
well what can you figure out how to make
peace with your idiot brother and
probably not because he's just as dumb
as you,
so the holiday hell are you going to
manage that?
And so then you've maybe you get
somewhere that way and your family sort
of functioning and you find out,
well that kind of relieved a little bit
of suffering,
although it reduce the opportunities for
spiteful revenge and that's kind of a
pain in the neck and so then you get
your family together a little bit and
your little clued in then at least a bit
because you've done something difficult
that's actually difficult.
You're a little wiser and so then maybe
you could put an tend to do finger out
beyond the family and try to change some
little thing without racking it.
It's like our society is complex and we
teach our students that they could just
fix it.
It's like go fix a military helicopter
and see how far you get with that.
It's like you're going to get a dude,
you're like a chimp with a wrench.
Whack.
Oh look,
it's better.
It's like,
no,
it's not better.
Things are complicated.
And to fix things is really hard and you
have to be like a golden tool to fix
things and you're not.
So,
and that's the other message of the
West.
It's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life?
And I'm not saying it's only the message
of the West.
How do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person.
That's how you do it.
Well,
that's hard.
It takes responsibility.
And I think,
you know,
if you said to someone,
you want to have a meaningful life,
everything you do matters.
That's a definition of a meaningful
life.
But everything you do matters,
you're going to have to carry that with
you.
Or do you want to just forget about the
whole meaning thing and then you don't
have any responsibility because who the
hell cares?
And you can wander through life doing
whatever you want,
gratifying,
impulsive desires for how useful that's
going to be.
And you're stuck in meaninglessness.
But you don't have any responsibility,
which one do you want?
Well,
ask yourself which one are you pursuing
and you'll find very rapidly that it
isn't the majority of your soul that's
pursuing the whole meaning thing
because,
well look what you have to do to do
that.
Yeah.
Have to take on the fact that life is
suffering.
You have put yourself together in the
face of that.
Well that's hard.
Christ,
it's amazing.
People can even do it.
I'm stunned every day when I go outside
and it isn't a re a riot with everything
burning.
It could really,
God you talk to people.
It's like I knew this guy,
he'd been in a motorcycle accident and
it really ruined him and he was like a
linesman,
you know,
working on the power and he was working
with someone who had Parkinson's disease
and they had complimentary inadequacies
and so two of them could do the job of
one person and so they're out there
fixing power lines in the freezing cold
despite the fact that one was three
quarters wrecked with a motorcycle
accident and the other one had
Parkinson's.
It's like that's how our works.
It's like there's all these ruled people
out there.
They've got problems like you can't
believe off.
They go to work and do things they don't
even like,
and look,
the lights are on.
My God.
It's unbelievable.
It's,
it's a miracle.
It's a miracle.
And we're so ungrateful.
College students,
the postmodern types,
they're so ungrateful.
You know,
they don't know that they're surrounded
by it.
Just a bloody miracle.
It's a miracle.
It all this stuff works that all you
crazy.
Chimpanzees that don't know each other
can sit in the same room for two hours,
sweltering away without tearing each
other apart because that's what chimps
do.
So
anyways,
so what happened?
Well,
I made some videos and I got to the
bottom of some things,
at least as far as I can tell.
So I told you what the bottom is and
then I got this idea about what you
might do about it,
which isn't my idea.
It's like,
it's not my idea.
It's an old,
old,
old idea.
It's far older than Christianity.
It's all,
it's the oldest story of mankind.
Get yourself together,
transcend your suffering,
see if you can be some kind of hero,
make the suffering in the world less.
Well,
that's the way forward as far as I can
tell,
if there isn't any way forward.
Knots,
what's under assault by the
postmodernists?
So look out,
cause they know exactly what they're
doing and they know exactly why they're
doing it.
And that's what it looks like to me.
So
that's it.
[inaudible].